i think it's hard to actually overstate
the significance of what has happened
here today these are the 39 subcoast
masters who were accused
of stealing because of mistakes that a
computer was making the computers
software was making it the
post office branches they were working
at people who in some cases were sent to
prison
were bankrupted some took their lives
before they even
got to see their day in court today and
their names finally
after decades being cleared i just saw
sima meestra one of those
postmasters outside court she had tears
in her eyes
she was convicted of stealing 75 000
pounds
from the post office in 2010 she was
eight weeks pregnant
when she was sent to prison for 15
months she said this is a moment that
she
has been thinking of for a very long
time but nothing
will bring back the shame that she felt
being sent to prison for a crime that
she never committed and that is a
sentiment that you hear
again and again here nothing will change
what has happened
but this is a historic moment a moment
they have been waiting for
for a very long time the post office for
their part
have said that they sincerely apologize
for the historical failures in a
statement today they said that
throughout this appeals process they
have supported the overwhelming
majority of these convictions and the
judgment today will be an important
milestone they say in addressing the
past
worth saying too that the post office
had already agreed a 58 million pound
settlement
with more than 500 postmasters which
does sound like a lot of money that was
in the separate civil case but in
reality most of that
went to the legal fund as an on legal
cost many of the postmasters didn't even
get back a fraction
of what they had already had to pay back
to the post office
this ruling today could now pave the way
for big
compensation for some of those
postmasters it is an important step on
the road
and of course a historic moment 39
postmasters
wrongly accused of stealing from the
post office today
have finally cleared their names and uh
who is going to carry the cat who or
what indeed who is to blame
uh who's going to have consequences for
the
terrible ordeal these postmasters and
mistresses have been put through
well there has been a huge amount of
pressure on the post office who is now
under new management um their former
chief executive
never did an interview on this in recent
months things seem to perhaps be
changing slightly
the new chief executive nick
reed the new chief executive of the post
office has said that he sincerely
apologizes has
said that he wants the government to do
more because of course the post office
is government owned there have been two
select committees
into this but really there is a sense
from the postmasters that no one has yet
been held to account so we wait to see
today whether we will hear more from the
post office perhaps it will be
that they do offer some sort of generous
settlement after this
but if not that will mean that the
postmasters once again have to go to
litigation and once again have to
take the post office to court in civil
claims and that obviously costs a lot of
money and is a long arduous process and
that is not something that anyone here
wants to happen again